[Music]
and we thank you for joining us on our
program. I'd like to know our favorite
Bible question and answer program here
at SumTV. My name is CA Murray and I'm
in the company of two distinguished
travelers on the road to glory, Pastor
David Salazar and Pastor Steven Bour.
Gentlemen, good to have you here as
always.
>> Amen.
>> We want to get right to our business
right right away. We want to do a little
housekeeping. Should you want to be part
of the program, and we pray that you do
and that you are, would you be pleased
to send an email to us, send it to
TVsumtv.org.
I repeat, tvsum,
su as in marytv.org.
and we will add your question to our
impressive list of questions and we will
get to it as soon as we can and give you
an answer from the word of God. That is
our pledge and our promise to you. If
your question is a biblical question, we
will give you indeed a biblical answer
because that's what it deserves. So send
it in and we'll get to it just as soon
as we can. For today's program, Pastor
Bo, I'm going to ask you if you would be
pleased to pray for us and then we'll
launch out into our questions for today.
Let's pray. Father in heaven, we come
before you today to thank you for the
privilege of having your word where we
can not only answer questions, but
through the power of the Holy Spirit, we
can be transformed into the image of
Christ. We ask that as we try to answer
these questions from your word, that
your Holy Spirit will be with us to
enlighten our minds, to sanctify our
tongues.
>> Amen. that we what we speak will be in
harmony with your word and a blessing to
those who are watching the program. We
thank you for hearing this prayer and
for answering because we ask it in the
precious and most holy name of Jesus.
Amen.
>> Amen and amen. As I look at our first
question, it comes from RS a couple of
things that we like. One, if you give us
your name, but also if you'll let us
know where you are writing from, that
gives us some idea of the footprint of
the ministry, where our ministry is
being felt and where it is touching
lives. It just gives us some idea, some
feedback from our audience uh where the
questions are coming from. So we thank
you in advance for that. Do include
where you are coming from, the country,
the continent, the planet if you will.
Uh we would like that that very much. it
would help us uh so very very much.
First question again, RS, we have the
initials. Um, dear pastors, many thanks
for your ministry. It is a great
blessing. Now, that's another thing that
we coveret. We like to know that what
we're doing is a blessing to our
constituency, to those who watch, to
those who listen, to those who are part
of our family. We like to know that what
we're doing is appreciated, but more
than that, it's helping advance the
kingdom of God. So, when you say it's a
great blessing, those are words that are
sort of music to our ears. And we thank
you Iris for that. The question is did
Jesus take our diseases to himself when
he touched sick people? Sick people for
example when he touched the leper did he
take the leprosy to himself? And rather
if that is the case why didn't he get
leprosy? Now she's referring to Luke
5:12. Which one of you worthy brethren
have have that?
>> I have uh the Luke 51213. But I think
that uh to answer this properly probably
best to read the second verse that she
mentions there or or he mentions there
Matthew 8:17
>> very much so
>> and the reason is because this is
probably where I can see uh this
individual this person has come to this
maybe concept it says there I'll read
actually verse 16 and 17 of Matthew 8 to
give a context to the question it reads
there when evening had come They brought
to him many who were demon-possessed.
And he cast out the spirits with a word
and healed all who were sick that it
might be fulfilled which was spoken by
Isaiah the prophet saying, "He himself
took our infirmities and bore our
sicknesses."
So this is, you know, Matthew 16:7 8:16.
And if you read this sort of what on the
surface, you may think that maybe Jesus
was when he was casting out demons or he
was healing because of the verse of
Isaiah 53:4 which is repeated here. The
idea that he bore our infirmities that
he bore our sickness may give the
illusion or the conclusion that maybe
he's when he's healing someone Jesus was
transferring the sickness onto himself.
However, um that is not necessarily what
is implied by this particular verse of
Isaiah and what is said in this verse.
As we actually read in the verse 16,
Jesus said he cast out demons. Uh now if
he was to bring the sickness to himself,
it would have mean that the demons would
also have been travelers to himself. I
mean using this logic concept. But the
idea is that the the demons are cast
out. And we know that in the healing of
the man that was demonp possessed of
gatherine he was the demons asked to be
sent to the pigs. So we know
particularly that is very clear that the
the demons never came to Christ or never
was they were placed on him. Now, as far
as sickness goes,
we know uh and in many places where is
he heals, it says that for example, the
case of Peter's mother-in-law, the fever
let her
>> and so Jesus did not put the fever on
himself. The fever was just healed.
That's what a healer would do. I mean,
Christ, divine healer, will actually
heal people from the sickness. He didn't
transfer that to himself. I know pastor,
you probably have something more to say
about this. You know this makes me think
of the lady who had the flow of blood.
>> You know she touched the uh garment of
Christ
>> and uh immediately Jesus says power has
gone out from me virtue. Right?
>> So it's not the case that Jesus is
assuming her disease
>> but rather his power is going out to
heal her disease. Right?
>> Uh if Jesus had become a leper uh he
would never have been able to continue
ministering because lepers were isolated
from society. Right.
>> And so this is simply a figurative
expression.
>> Yes.
>> That simply means that Jesus uh healed
the diseases of the people he came in
contact with like you were saying.
>> Um by the way this text this is actually
a quotation from the Old Testament.
>> It comes from Isaiah 53 and verse4
>> where it says surely he has borne our
griefs and carried our sorrows. Uh so
that's the way that it's translated in
the New King James version. He has borne
our griefs and our sorrows. Uh but one
of those words does mean sicknesses,
>> but it doesn't mean that Jesus assumed
the sickness upon himself
>> to heal somebody else.
>> The the the problem is a
poor exugesus of bore. Uh there is a a
general evangelical feeling that Christ
carried our sicknesses by bringing them
unto himself. No, he healed disease. He
healed it. He cured it. He didn't he
didn't uh and and and really the burden
of of this text is spiritual things
>> more than physical although it does deal
with the physical also.
>> So Christ didn't have to take your cold,
>> you know, to cure you. He can cure your
cold.
>> Amen.
>> Um he don't have to care. He didn't have
to carry your your your toothache, you
know, he can cure your toothache. Uh and
because of the power that was with him.
So it's it's an u dare I say a faulty
evangelical exugesus of the word bore
that not Steven bore but bore.
>> Thank you very much
bore our diseases. Uh and um once you
get a correct understanding of that it
tends to fall into line as you said
Pastor David and we appreciate that.
>> Right. And and you know also just to
make a notice on the verse that she that
this individual mentions Luke 5:12-13
in Luke 5:12-13 again when the Lord
comes to this leper I'm going to read
the verses it says and it happened when
he was in a certain city that behold a
man who was full of leprosy saw Jesus
and he fell on his face and implored him
saying Lord if you are willing you can
make me clean. Then he put out his hand
and touched him saying, "I am willing be
cleansed." Immediately the leprosy left
him. So again, this is not a transfer.
The Bible is never saying transfer to
Christ. The leprosy left him. Again,
Christ can heal in his presence. Disease
can be wiped out, can be left uh can be
destroyed, can be overcome by the power
of Christ. And back to the verse that we
mentioned in Isaiah 54 53:4 where it
says that he bore our infirmities. And
uh it's really dealing with more of the
concept of he taking on our nature,
taking our our human form, our human
nature. And he understands what it means
to suffer hunger, pain, uh separation,
all these things. And this is what this
verse in Isaiah is more implying. is not
necessarily that he came as a magician
in a way or to bring the you know I
don't know get some some of the stuff on
him is meaning that his nature he came
as a human being with our infirmities
with our uh fallen nature if you will so
that he could be like us and overcome by
the power of God working in him. So in a
sense it's it's really that expression
that is mainly meaning not necessarily
that he was like you said transferring
things on himself. Yeah.
>> You know, Ellen White has a very
interesting statement uh in Desire of
Ages in the chapter on the resurrection
of Lazarus. She says that sometimes
Jesus would go through a town
>> and when he came out on the other side,
there was not one sick person left in
the town, right?
>> Well, did Jesus uh assume all of the
diseases upon himself of those towns? Of
course not.
>> Yes. Uh so so basically uh you're
correct uh in your assessment that uh
Jesus did not literally take the disease
that somebody that he healed had.
>> Uh it simply means that Jesus healed
people through his power.
>> Yeah, we were thinking the exact same
thing. El says sometimes he spent all
day healing, all night in prayer. All
day healing, all night in prayer. Can
you imagine if he had to take all those
diseases on himself? it just it
theologically it doesn't really add up
and and certain biblically is not
supported
>> and you can also make uh reme you know
remember that the disciples themselves
had the same power to cast out demons to
heal disease and so they never took upon
themselves the disease themsel you know
itself but they actually like like the
power of Christ working through them
they were able to heal those that were
sick.
>> Yeah. You know that something popped
into my mind and we could talk about
this all day. You know, Ellen White says
that that Judas as one of the disciples
also had the power to heal. God gave him
that that that power. Uh and uh of
course, when he saw Christ healing, his
heart was thrilled, but he had so many
other issues. So, the disciples had that
ability also. So, they certainly weren't
taking diseases onto themselves. They
had enough to deal with with their own
faults and and foibless. Uh so, good
question and we thank you for that.
>> Um let's move to Caleb. Again, we have
no location, but Caleb, thank you for
your question. Uh, the question reads, I
have come across Hebrews chapter 9 verse
12. So, I guess we ought to turn there.
>> Hebrews 9:12. And I have a question.
>> It seems that every version except the
King James uses the phrase, he entered
into the most holy place once and for
all.
This does not seem to be in harmony,
excuse me, with our position. When we
say our position, he's talking about the
7th Day Adventist Church's position on
Christ going into the most holy place in
1844.
I've heard this text used to prove that
Christ went straight into the most holy
place upon his ass as
it should be ascension to heaven instead
of the holy place. Could you please
explain this verse? Let's read the
verse.
>> Okay. I have uh Hebrews 9:12.
It reads, "Not with blood of goats and
cal cults, but with his own blood he
entered the most holy place once for
all, having obtained eternal
redemption." This is the New King James
version of the Bible.
>> All righty. Um, the question says,
um, it seems that every version except
the King James version uses the phrase,
"He entered into the most holy place
once and for all." That's not true.
>> Uh, let me read you, uh, what some of
the versions. I looked up many, many
versions.
>> So did I.
>> Uh, New King James Version, most holy
place. NIV, most holy place. Um, uh, the
contemporary English version, most holy
place. the English standard version,
holy places,
>> you know, and the the expression in
Greek is tahaga,
which literally means holy places. Taga
is plural.
>> So, he went into the into the holy
places.
>> Um, the Living Bible, Holy of Holies,
uh, the New uh, English translation,
most holy place. The New Revised
Standard Version, Holy Place. the
revised standard version, holy place.
Young's literal translation, holy
places,
>> and Tindel, which is of course a very
old version, holy place.
>> Yes.
>> So, it's not true that that all versions
other than the King James translates
most holy place. Um, it the fact that
you have so many different translations
indicates that the translators are
struggling with uh the the proper
translation of Tahaga.
>> Yes. Right.
Uh, one other thing that I might mention
is it's very clear that Jesus did not go
into the most holy place of the
sanctuary. All you have to do is read
Revelation chapter 1 where Jesus is
walking among the candlesticks, the
seven candlesticks in the holy place.
>> In the holy place
>> in his glorified form.
>> Mhm.
>> And then in the series on the trumpets,
he's uh at the altar of incense. Mhm.
>> ministering at the altar of incense
which is in the holy place.
>> It's absolutely absurd to believe that
Jesus came and lived in our camp uh
here. He dwelt among us in in the camp
of the sanctuary and then he died at the
altar so to speak and then he
resurrected at the labor and then he
jumped over the holy place into the most
holy place. It does not fit the sequence
of the sanctuary.
>> Amen. I I think that there is, you know,
with what pastor Bor was mentioning in
regards to the many translators having
issues or or not being consistent in
translating this word as most holy place
or just as holy places uh or sanctuary
in some other versions. Uh we can
definitely make it a case that the
translation is not necessarily correct
with most holy place and many versions
prove that. So that's that's one thing
but as you mentioned the concept of
Christ what this verse is implying is
that there is no need for another
sacrifice his own blood was sufficient
so that he could enter into the holy
place or to the sanctuary. Um just
looking into the concept of the
tabernacle systems the you know the the
the um sanctuary system on the old
testament we know what the process was
after the slaying of the lamb what was
required in the next step. So we can
actually using that example of the
sanctuary very clearly understand what
it means what when Paul is explaining
here to the Hebrews what happened when
Christ was sacrificed how he was offered
and he was able to enter into the holy
place or the sanctuary or the holy
places once and for all like that's once
is enough. There's no need for him to
continue. So that's why it's important
to look at the context of what he's
trying to say and not just go by what
one verse or one translator rather or
translation uh implies to a a word that
as you mentioned uh tag tahaka it's uh
meant here by some individuals
>> and in the daily service
the priest entered the holy place and
sprinkled the blood on the veil
>> right
>> which represents the intercession
>> of Jesus of the of Jesus Christ.
>> So Jesus is not going to skip the holy
place and go directly into the most holy
place. Yeah.
>> It it's against reason
>> and it's also against scripture.
Exactly.
>> It's not it's not logical.
>> Amen. There are many benefits
>> found in the holy place that that that
Christ performed. uh you've got the
veil, you've got the the bread, you've
got so there's much symbolism that if
you jump over it, you lose the the
burden of that of that particular part
of the sanctuary.
>> Um
>> Oh, I know. Uh let me turn you into a
Bible scholar. Um Caleb, uh there's an
there's an app, we all have it, uh
called Bible Hub.
Bible Hub will give you, if you look up
a particular text, it will give you the
translation of that text in 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18, 19, 20 plus translation. So,
uh, when you make a saying that most,
uh, versions have this kind of, uh,
digest of this, you can quickly see
through Bible Hub what most of them are
are saying. Uh, that's what I had. I
don't know where you got yours from,
Pastor Bo. I assume you got it from
Bible Hub also, or maybe another because
there are plenty of them that will tell
you what it says. So, you can compare
and compare and compare. Uh, back in the
old days, I used to lay out all these
Bibles in front of me when I was writing
sermons, you know. uh this computer has
made me a genius you know
>> it's turned me into a biblical scholar
just by uh downloading Bible hub so that
will help you in in your wrestling with
text because it sort of lines them out
before and remember what is happening in
the book of Hebrews Hebrews was written
to to uh Hebrew Christians who were
considering among other things going
back to to a religion that they were
familiar with you know uh being a
Christian was was rough stuff in the
Roman times Mhm.
>> And so it was a religion illicit us.
Well, at least Judaism was accepted.
Maybe we ought to go back to Judaism.
And Hebrews is written to tell you that
no, Judaism is is not going to save you
now. It's all about Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> That was good. Jesus is better.
>> That was good. Jesus is better. So you
see this this this play. That's good.
>> This is better. You know, over and over
again. So you don't want to go back, you
want to go forward. And uh so when
Christ is in the the the sanctuary,
that's what it's trying to to tell you
as opposed to a specific apartment in in
the sanctuary.
>> And it's important to, you know, make a
note that um Hebrews was written to that
you mentioned, pastor, to to Jewish
Christians that understood very well and
knew the concepts of the Old Testament
and what the sanctuary service was and
whatnot. A lot of times what people uh
that you know come this assumptions that
one verse means that Christ went to the
most holy place for example it's really
a lack of understanding or ignorance on
the system of the sanctuary in the old
testament and this is why they come to
these conclusions based on a erroneous
translation or not a perfect translation
rather so it's important that we help
individuals to understand the lessons in
the whole word of god the bible the old
testament so that things that are
particular in case you know regarding to
the century they understand what the
process was and why the Bible will help
you understand how Jesus fulfilled each
aspect of the century.
>> Well said. Last comment before this. You
never want to develop a doctrinal
premise on one point of scripture, one
one text.
>> Uh when the Bible says here a little,
there a little it it it really is giving
you a methodology for understanding the
word of God. you see something here that
confuses you or that seems to go against
the teaching, then go back and find it
in other places. And the Bible is the
best exposure of excuse me, of itself.
It will explain itself to you if you
take the time. One thing about Bible
study, you brethren both know, you can't
rush it.
>> It's not it's not fast food.
>> You can't get through it in in in one
sitting, you know. You've got to you've
got to take it slowly and compare.
before William Miller uh came out with
his thesis
>> decade decade and a little bit more. He
took a lot of time working his way
through the Bible. We tend to want to
have it our way. You know, okay, that's
what it means. Well, it may not mean
that. Look someplace else and see what
what it what it means. Well, I believe
that one of the reasons why uh these
versions translate most holy place is
because uh they want to deny
the 7th avenous view of Jesus going into
the most holy place in 1844. Mhm.
>> And of course behind that is a problem
that they don't go to the book of Daniel
to study the prophecy of the 2300 days
or they make those days literal and they
apply them to Antioch's
>> Epiphanies. Yes. Yeah.
>> And so, and so because they try to
interpret it, interpret Hebrews 9:12
just on its own without going to the
book of Daniel, without going to the
book of Revelation, uh they reach wrong
conclusions.
>> Uh and even many Seventh Day Adventist
scholars uh say that uh Jesus went
directly into the most holy place.
Unfortunately,
>> uh you know, when he ascended to heaven.
But uh when you look at all of the
evidence, like you were saying, CA, when
you look at all of the evidence of
scripture,
>> it's very clear that Jesus went from the
cross to the resurrection to the holy
place.
>> Yes.
>> And then later on to the most holy place
of the sanctuary. That and then of
course in the future you still have the
asasil. Yeah. uh ceremony which is the
thousand years where Satan is exiled to
a desolate planet earth.
>> So the sanctuary just follows uh the
steps of Christ's ministry uh one by one
in perfect order.
>> You know I'm going to say something
which which may sound a bit blasphemous
and we're coming down to our last
several seconds here.
>> There are certain Bibles that are
written with an agenda.
You know you really and that's why you
need to compare Bibles. I uh someone
sent me years ago a Jerusalem Bible
>> and as I began to work through it,
>> it's got an agenda, you know, it has an
agenda. Uh and I talked to you about we
were talking about that and you said,
"Yeah, it's got an agenda, you know,
kind of thing." Now, interestingly
enough, the Jerusalem Bible is not
listed here with with these others. I
don't I don't see it. But um so I've got
it. I don't ever throw Bibles away. It's
on the shelf, right?
>> But I don't just run to the Jerusalem
Bible because it has it has an agenda.
And there are other Bibles written uh
with with an agenda. again. Uh, thank
you for joining us today. We hope that
our musings today have been a blessing
to you. We'll see you again soon.
Bye-bye and God bless.
[Music]